hi everyone this is the third part in a
series of videos looking at stuff
sparring if you haven't seen the other
two videos I recommend going and watch
them first I'll post links in the
description below so this video is going
to focus on sparring with the plastic
stuff like last time I'm gonna let the
video play through then I'll go through
it and break it down in slow motion okay
so here I start on the right wearing
black shoes Rogers on the left wearing
white shoes
[Music]
okay so let's start with this part where
I drop down and go for Rajas leg those
that do Aikido will recognize this from
the 31 count car I managed to strike his
leg however don't draw back quick enough
and he gets a counter straight to my
hand it can be hard to tell inspiring if
the same strike with the hard stuff and
no protection will give opportunity for
enough to blow what account would be
possible I will go into that now but
it's new topic to think about so here
Raj goes for a thrust and I move off
line for a strike if I freeze a clip you
can see how flexible the stuff actually
is this is good for reducing impact but
those change the feeling quite a lot in
comparison to a standard Jones in this
exchange no significant strike was made
but thought it'd be interesting to point
out a couple of things after I go for a
strike Raj comes back with a count at
racing his Joe undermine this makes me
think he's going for a high strike but
then he drops it and goes for my leg as
he does this I step out the way and try
and counter by going for his hands Raj
however picks up on this by raising his
staff up to cover these intricacies can
easily be overlooked unless watch back
in slow motion so this next part is a
similar type of parry seen in the 13
count car although the pair is
successful I miss a good opportunity to
counter as you can see I'm fully loaded
for a high thrust however instead I turn
over the job for a mid-level thrust
this gives Raj enough time to get out of
distance here I hit Raj with the one
under strike to the head as soon as the
opens up I go straight in for the strike
as you can see only just made contact
which is why I went for a one-handed
strike as opposed to a 200 strike as it
covers more distance in this clip Raj
goes for a one-handed strike and I use a
block similar to that used in the fifth
Kumu job to provide cover although I
thought he was going high his strike to
Osman II was still covered by the middle
of my staff
the defense in this clip is similar to
that of the previous one however rather
than stopping I continue the movement
which makes it more like a figure eight
hustle so here I go for a strike and Raj
keeps his jaw extended to try push me
back this type of strike seems to come
up quite a lot as this regular practice
with both the sword and stuff I go for
the same strike in this clip however I
miss and get my Joe caught and Rodgers
jacket you can see the flex of the stuff
again as normally should stop horizontal
of the momentum causes the stuff to been
quite a lot Raj goes for a strike
however I moved back out the way if
we're grappling this would have been the
ideal time to engage so here I go for a
thrust and Raj counters with the strike
then it's followed up by a couple of
exchanges so looking at in slow motion
Raj strikes and makes contact with my
hand after we separate I go for another
thrust this time I get through to Raj
his neck however he medially counters
with another strike to my neck so in
this clip I get two consecutive strikes
in to begin with Raj opens up and I
strike his elbow he tries to get enough
to blow but it strikes my stuff between
my hands I then switch to the opposite
side and strike his head so in terms of
the plastic staff the proportions are
the nearest to the wooden jaw that I'd
normally train with the smooth hard
surface makes it good to handle when
changing grips however the lack of
weight and over flexing still makes it
quite different that being said it works
quite well for sparring and the rubber
ends spread the impacts on the throws
compared with the form staff it has
overall better handling and works better
in binds anyway I hope you enjoyed the
video if you did give it a thumbs up and
remember to subscribe for more videos
like this the next one will be looking
at sparring with a rat enjoy until then
take care